This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？香蒜酱能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman, Angel Geratana, Jeremy Colhane, Patrick McDonald.
在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman、Angel Geratana、Jeremy Colhane、Patrick McDonald。
And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artist Podcast. The improvised character comedy podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other.
我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，一起听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。我们有时也会做一点万圣节的内容。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。就在麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛碰撞的声音。
You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey everybody, it's me, Debbie Kumabelle. This season on my podcast who's with me, I speak with Bruce Lee's daughter, Brandon Lee's sister, and my friend Shannon Lee. Back to your initial point of stewarding my father's legacy. and giving my energy to that.
你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。大家好，我是Debbie Kumabelle。本季在我的播客《谁和我在一起》中，我采访了李小龙的女儿、李国豪的妹妹，也是我的朋友Shannon Lee。回到你最初提到的关于管理我父亲遗产并为此投入精力的观点。
You're lending your life to stewarding somebody else's life. Listen to Who's With Me with me with Debbie Cromwell on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Pice Thomas, and on this season of the Black Lits podcast,
你正在把你的生命借给别人去管理。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听我和Debbie Cromwell的《谁和我在一起》。是否存在一种针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是针对黑人文学。我是Jack Quist-Pice Thomas，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，
we're outside asking why. They don't want a whole bunch of little elevators, Michael Maxis and Martin with the King, And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. What up? This Jay Valentine co-host of the R&B Money Podcast alongside my brother, R&B legend, Tank. Together, we've built a space for artists, executives, and fans of R&B music to reminisce and tell the real stories behind the music.
我们走出去询问原因。他们不想要一大堆小埃尔维斯、马尔科姆·X和马丁·路德·金。当你审视许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。怎么了？我是Jay Valentine，与我的兄弟、R&B传奇人物Tank共同主持《R&B金钱》播客。我们共同为R&B音乐的艺术家、高管和粉丝建立了一个空间，让他们回忆并讲述音乐背后的真实故事。
I have no money. I was hood famous. They think you're going to get everybody out. We lived in a project. Real love came out. They're hearing the music and we had nothing. From Smokey Robinson to Mary J. Blige, B2K to Jill Scott. If you're a super dedicated R&B fan, this is where you belong. Listen to R&B money from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我没钱。我曾在街区很有名。他们以为你会把每个人都带出来。我们住在廉租房里。真正的爱出现了。他们听着音乐，而我们一无所有。从Smokey Robinson到Mary J. Blige，从B2K到Jill Scott。如果你是一个超级忠实的R&B粉丝，这里就是你的归宿。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《R&B金钱》。
Hello, everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes. moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. A quick reminder that this episode and many others are now available to watch on Netflix. I know I say it like every episode, but if you haven't yet, please check it out. It is one of the easiest ways to support the show and to support the podcast, and I would just really,
大家好。我是Jemma Spike，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们要在这里剖析你二十岁的心理。快速提醒一下，这一集和许多其他集现在可以在Netflix上观看。我知道我每一集都这么说，但如果你还没看，请去看看。这是支持节目和播客最简单的方法之一，如果你们有时间，我真的，
really deeply appreciate it if you have the time. Thank you. Today I want to talk about a feeling so many women know very, very intimately. The belief that the only way to be happy, loved, cared for is to make sure that everybody else is happy first. I want to introduce you to a term for this. It's called Good Girl Syndrome. Also known as Good Girl Complex. This isn't a formal psychological diagnosis. I want to say that straight away, but it does describe a collection of what we would call learnt compliance patterns that can be hard to recognize, specifically where women chronically suppress their authentic needs and chronically suppress their emotions to maintain approval and to avoid conflict believing that will make them happier,
真的会非常感激。谢谢。今天我想谈谈一种许多女性都非常、非常熟悉的感觉。那种认为要获得幸福、被爱、被关心的唯一途径就是确保其他人先幸福的信念。我想向你们介绍一个术语，叫“乖乖女综合症”。也称为“乖乖女情结”。这不是一个正式的心理学诊断。我想直接说明这一点，但它确实描述了一系列我们称之为习得性顺从模式的行为，这些模式可能很难识别，特别是女性长期压抑自己真实需求和情绪，以维持认可并避免冲突，认为这样会让自己更快乐，
or those around them happier. Those of us with Good Girl Syndrome have internalized these social behaviors and lessons, most often from a very young age, that the best thing that you can be is liked and loved, regardless of what it costs. And for yourself sacrificing and for yourself silencing, you will be rewarded. And we see it in our mothers,
或者让周围的人更快乐。我们这些患有“乖乖女综合症”的人，已经内化了这些社会行为和教训，通常是从很小的时候开始的，即你能成为的最好的事情就是被喜欢和被爱，无论付出什么代价。为了自我牺牲和自我沉默，你会得到回报。我们在母亲身上看到这一点，
we see it in our grandmothers, we see it in how women are expected to act at work and in relationships, and that is to always forgive and always to step aside and to be nice and to be demure and to be mindful. But this has a severe cost and it presents a very impossible tightrope for women, which is either you make everyone else happy by never asking questions or never demanding anything, or you allow yourself to be happy. And maybe in the process you upset some people or you're labelled a bitch, like or you
我们在祖母身上看到这一点，我们在女性在工作和人际关系中被期望表现出的方式中看到这一点，那就是总是原谅，总是退让，要表现得友善、端庄和体贴。但这付出了沉重的代价，它为女性呈现了一根不可能的钢丝，要么你通过从不提问或从不要求任何东西来让每个人都快乐，要么你允许自己快乐。也许在这个过程中，你会惹恼一些人，或者你会被贴上“婊子”的标签，或者你
receive consequences for that. That is the tightrope. And I think when we're walking that tightrope, good girl syndrome can slowly and secretly really erode our lives and erode our sense of self-confidence and self-worth. So I want to interrogate the psychological origins, the signs you may have developed this complex, this syndrome, why it often feels useful. And probably most importantly for an episode like this, what does the research say about unlearning these behaviors, especially after years and years of feeling like this is keeping you safe, this is keeping you loved, and this is part of who you are. So it's a big episode. I hope you enjoy it. Let's get into it. Good Girl Syndrome is one of those funny things where you never really notice it
会因此受到惩罚。这就是那根钢丝。我认为当我们走在那根钢丝上时，“乖乖女综合症”会悄悄地、秘密地真正侵蚀我们的生活，侵蚀我们的自信心和自我价值感。所以我想审视一下心理起源、你可能已经发展出这种情结或综合症的迹象，为什么它通常感觉很有用。对于这样一集节目来说，可能最重要的是，研究对于改掉这些行为有什么说法，特别是在多年来感觉这能让你安全、让你被爱，并且这是你的一部分之后。所以这是一集很重要的节目。希望你喜欢。让我们开始吧。“乖乖女综合症”是那种你永远不会真正注意到的有趣事情之一，
or you never really have a term for it. You just kind of think that it's like this natural thing that women do and the way they are. And then you have a word for it. You learn the term and the concept and it's literally everywhere. Everywhere women exist, there is an expectation for them to be good and polite and silent. And that is an expectation that just doesn't exist in the same way for men. I'm going to provide three examples to begin with of how this presents itself at every single stage of society. Firstly, in school.
或者你从来没有一个术语来形容它。你只是觉得这是女性做的自然的事情，是她们本来的样子。然后你就有了一个词来形容它。你学习了这个术语和概念，它简直无处不在。在女性存在的每一个地方，都有对她们要乖巧、礼貌和沉默的期望。而这种期望对男性来说并不存在。我首先要提供三个例子，说明这在社会的每一个阶段是如何表现出来的。首先，在学校。
Disruptiveness when we're at school from boys is expected and it's almost seen as part of their learning process or playful and boys being boys and, you know, it's fine. Whereas disruptiveness from girls are seen as disrespectful, it's seen as rude, unexpected. Girls are also expected to police boys' behavior. You know, if a boy is loud and misbehaving, have a guess who he's sitting next to. You know, most likely, if it's not the teacher, it's a nice good girl, his same age, he's going to rub off on him, even though that's not really her responsibility. You know, she's there to learn. She's not his mother. She's not a babysitter. She's his peer, but she's a good girl, and she's going to sit
男孩在学校的破坏性行为是被预期的，这几乎被视为他们学习过程的一部分，或者是顽皮，男孩就是男孩，你知道，这没关系。而女孩的破坏性行为则被视为不尊重，被视为粗鲁、出乎意料。女孩也被期望去监管男孩的行为。你知道，如果一个男孩大声喧哗、行为不端，猜猜他坐在谁旁边。你知道，最有可能的是，如果不是老师，那就是一个和他同龄的、可爱的乖女孩，他会对他产生影响，尽管这并不是她的责任。你知道，她是去学习的。她不是他的母亲。她不是保姆。她是他的同龄人，但她是一个乖女孩，她会坐得
nicely and politely, and she's going to do it, and she's maybe even going to feel proud of this maturity and proud of this duty. Then we have good girl syndrome in relationships. A good girl will keep the peace. She will manage the emotions and the mental load of her partner, and the more subtly that she can do this, the more low maintenance she can be. And the more low maintenance, the better. I often think low maintenance in these cases is often code for, you know, doesn't ask for much, doesn't need much, doesn't push back, meaning maximum freedom often for her male partner at the expense of her own emotions. So we have good girl syndrome in school, good girl syndrome in relationships, then we have good girl syndrome in politics. A good girl in this situation
很好、很礼貌，她会照做，她甚至可能会为这种成熟和这种责任感感到自豪。然后我们在人际关系中也有“乖乖女综合症”。一个乖女孩会维持和平。她会管理伴侣的情绪和心理负担，她能越微妙地做到这一点，她就越能保持低维护成本。而且维护成本越低越好。我经常认为在这些情况下，“低维护”通常是代号，意思是，你知道，不要求太多，不需要太多，不反抗，这意味着她的男性伴侣通常以牺牲她自己的情绪为代价获得最大的自由。所以我们在学校有“乖乖女综合症”，在人际关系中有“乖乖女综合症”，然后我们在政治中也有“乖乖女综合症”。在这种情况下，一个乖女孩
will be delicate. She won't be too outspoken and she definitely won't break any rules. It was a study from 2025 at Durham University, aimed to understand whether female politicians are held to hire more rigid standards in comparison to male politicians. And what these researchers did was that they created a fictional US congressional election. And they asked participants to evaluate and to eventually vote for made-up candidates. And what the results showed was that female candidates were judged more harshly than male candidates when they violated certain expectations. Women received a larger penalty for straying from what was expected from them, whilst male candidates were given a lot more leeway. Even when they were involved in serious misconduct,
会很谨慎。她不会太直言不讳，她绝对不会违反任何规则。这是杜伦大学2025年的一项研究，旨在了解女性政治家是否比男性政治家受到更高、更严格的标准要求。这些研究人员所做的是创建了一个虚构的美国国会选举。他们要求参与者评估并最终投票给虚构的候选人。结果显示，当女性候选人违反某些期望时，她们受到的评价比男性候选人更严厉。女性因偏离对她们的期望而受到更大的惩罚，而男性候选人则被给予了更多的回旋余地。即使当他们涉及严重的不当行为时，
they were often forgiven by the voter. There just wasn't the same expectation on men to be good and to care or be mindful for others. And these broader expectations, I think these three explanations show how this phenomenon reaches everything and everyone. But in ourselves, what does it look like? I want to give you some individual signs. This may be part of your own behavior or your own identity, as I know it's part of mine, so that you can kind of look out for it. And no judgment in this.
他们也经常被选民原谅。男性并没有同样的期望去表现得乖巧、去关心或体贴他人。我认为这三个解释展示了这种现象如何触及一切和每个人。但在我们自己身上，它看起来是什么样的？我想给你一些个人的迹象。这可能是你自身行为或自身身份的一部分，因为我知道这是我的一部分，这样你就可以留意它。而且对此没有评判。
I just think it's a helpful thing to just see if you relate to how this is individually expressed. Firstly, a big sign of good girl syndrome is over explaining, over explaining everything and over apologising for everything. Even neutral statements will begin with, sorry, but I'm sorry, but this, that, you know, we might come up with a large list of reasons that, you know, we can't attend things. We don't just say no. We have to give evidence for our choice. We have to make sure people know, if I'm saying no, if I'm disagreeing with you, if I can't come, it's all my fault. It's all on me. can just forgive me now. I'll feel terrible about it in my own time. At its root, over-explaining and over-apologizing is an anxiety response. We don't want anyone to think poorly of us, anyone,
我只是认为看看你是否与这种个人表达方式产生共鸣是有帮助的。首先，“乖乖女综合症”的一个大迹象是过度解释，对一切过度解释，对一切过度道歉。即使是中性的陈述也会以“抱歉，但是……”、“我很抱歉，但是……”开头，你知道，我们可能会列出一大堆理由，你知道，我们不能参加某些活动。我们不仅仅是说“不”。我们必须为我们的选择提供证据。我们必须确保人们知道，如果我说“不”，如果我不同意你的观点，如果我不能来，那都是我的错。这都是我的责任。现在就原谅我吧。我会在自己的时间里为此感到难过。从根本上说，过度解释和过度道歉是一种焦虑反应。我们不想让任何人对我们有不好的看法，任何人，
because that would mean that we've let somebody down. And as a good girl, like, your nervous system literally just doesn't know how to cope with that. It doesn't have the strategy to feel okay in this situation of ambiguity and disappointment. The same applies to our opinions, and our ability to express them. A classic sign of good girl syndrome is just not being able to stand up for something that you deeply believe in when somebody else disagrees with you, specifically out of fear that you disagreeing will come off as combative or contrarian and will make them upset. You could have a belief that you deeply believe in more than anything else in the world. But as soon as somebody else says, you know, I don't actually agree with that.
因为那意味着我们让某人失望了。作为一个乖女孩，你的神经系统真的不知道如何应对这种情况。它没有策略在模棱两可和失望的情况下感到自在。这同样适用于我们的观点，以及我们表达观点的能力。乖乖女综合症的一个典型迹象是，当别人不同意你的观点时，你无法坚持自己深信不疑的事情，特别是出于担心你的不同意会被视为好斗或唱反调，并会让他们不高兴。你可能有一个比世界上任何东西都更深信不疑的信念。但一旦别人说，你知道，我其实不同意那个，
this is my opinion, it's something different, you become very agreeable. Like, even if it's against your own moral, sometimes it's really hard to stand up for that. You even, you know, I think will often end up walking away being like, I wish that I'd done that differently. I wish that I'd pushed harder. In the moment, if you have this good girl complex, it literally feels impossible. It is paralyzing. I remember doing an interview with somebody last year, and if you are a loyal listener, I honestly, I think you could guess. I think you guys kind of know which one. And it really woke me up to my own good girl tendencies because if I'm being completely honest, this guest was saying things I honestly didn't agree with. And I always thought that I was
这是我的观点，它是不同的，你就会变得非常随和。就像，即使它违背了你自己的道德，有时真的很难坚持这一点。你甚至，你知道，我想通常会走开，心想，我希望我当时能做得不同。我希望我当时能更坚持一点。在那一刻，如果你有这种乖乖女情结，它真的感觉是不可能的。它是令人瘫痪的。我记得去年采访某人，如果你是一个忠实的听众，我真的认为你可以猜到。我想你们大概知道是哪一个。它真的让我意识到了我自己的乖乖女倾向，因为如果我完全诚实的话，这位嘉宾说的话我真的不同意。而且我一直认为我是
strong-willed about and that if somebody said these things to me, I would know what to say and I would fight back in those situations. And in that moment, I just was, I froze and I didn't want to upset this complete stranger. So I just kind of politely nodded along. That is good girl syndrome. In that situation, I knew what I believed. I knew what I should say. I knew I had a right to push back and to disagree. And I just couldn't. And the reason I couldn't because I was like, well, what if this stranger who will never think of me or hear from me or see me again has a negative opinion? What if I upset them? I mean, well, I'm sitting there upset, but, you know, my feelings don't matter as much. It's this passivity that just creeps up on us in so many areas of our life where,
意志坚强的，如果有人对我这么说，我会知道该说什么，我会在那些情况下反击。但在那一刻，我只是，我僵住了，我不想让这个完全陌生的人不高兴。所以我只是礼貌地点头。这就是“乖乖女综合症”。在那种情况下，我知道我相信什么。我知道我应该说什么。我知道我有权反击和不同意。但我就是做不到。我做不到的原因是因为我想，好吧，如果这个永远不会想到我、听到我或再见到我的陌生人有负面看法怎么办？如果我让他们不高兴怎么办？我的意思是，好吧，我坐在那里很难过，但是，你知道，我的感受并不那么重要。这种被动感在我们的生活中很多领域悄悄出现，在这些领域，
ways we're very assertive, we're very successful, we're very opinionated, but then there is like this instinct that kicks in at times like unconsciously. Another sign that you may be or may have good girl syndrome is that you are incredibly attuned to others' emotions. Often to, I would say, a psychic almost freaky degree. Like you can tell somebody is mad weeks before they say anything. You can tell when somebody isn't happy in their relationship. They don't need to tell you anything. They don't need to say a word. You know, I feel like in these moments,
我们非常自信，我们非常成功，我们非常有主见，但随后在某些时候会下意识地出现一种本能。你可能患有或可能有“乖乖女综合症”的另一个迹象是，你对他人的情绪极其敏锐。通常，我会说，达到一种近乎通灵、近乎怪异的程度。就像你可以在某人说出任何话之前的几周就知道他们生气了。你可以看出某人在恋爱关系中是否不快乐。他们不需要告诉你任何事情。他们不需要说一个字。你知道，我觉得在这些时刻，
like your friends are probably sick of hearing. You say, I told you so. But this is your superpower. Being able to identify discomfort in others and rushing in to fix it is a job you are very good at. And there is a word for this. There's always a word for these things in psychology, and it's hypervigilance.
你的朋友可能已经厌倦了听你说“我早就告诉过你了”。但这正是你的超能力。能够识别他人的不适并冲过去解决它是一项你非常擅长的工作。有一个词可以形容这一点。在心理学中，这些事情总有一个词，那就是“过度警觉”。
You've probably heard of it. But it's a state of chronic aloneness where your attention is always focused outwards. It's always closely monitoring the reactions and emotions of others in your environment, rather than monitoring and regulating how you feel internally. We just want everyone to have a good time. We want everyone to be happy. And if they're happy, who cares if I'm unhappy in the process?
你可能听说过它。但它是一种长期孤独的状态，你的注意力总是向外聚焦。它总是密切监测环境中他人的反应和情绪，而不是监测和调节你内心的感受。我们只是希望每个人都玩得开心。我们希望每个人都快乐。如果他们快乐，我在这个过程中不快乐又有什么关系呢？
I think there's this narrative of like, I can manage my own bad feelings, but I don't trust that others can do the same. and I don't believe that they should, because unlike me, they shouldn't have to sacrifice that. The good girl sacrifices her own comfort for others and therefore feels that she will be rewarded. Other people's unhappiness is much, much more uncomfortable to her than her own. In this vein, I think another classic symptom sign of good girl syndrome is also constantly over-analysing minor social interactions. specifically after they've already taken place, were days before,
我认为有一种叙事是，我可以管理我自己的坏情绪，但我并不相信别人也能做到。而且我不认为他们应该这样做，因为不像我，他们不应该不得不做出那种牺牲。乖女孩为了他人牺牲自己的舒适，因此觉得她会得到回报。他人的不快乐对她来说比她自己的不快乐要难受得多、多得多。在这种情况下，我认为“乖乖女综合症”的另一个典型症状迹象也是不断地过度分析微小的社交互动。特别是在它们已经发生之后，几天前，
you're still looking for signs that you were rude or that you were off-putting. I think the other critical thing is like asking for reassurance from a friend or a partner or somebody else that was there, like, oh, can you just confirm, was I rude? Do you think they liked me? Was I weird? Even if there is literally no sign that others were upset or bored or offended,
你还在寻找你粗鲁或令人反感的迹象。我认为另一个关键的事情是，比如向朋友、伴侣或当时在场的其他人寻求安慰，比如，哦，你能确认一下吗，我粗鲁吗？你觉得他们喜欢我吗？我很奇怪吗？即使实际上没有任何迹象表明其他人感到不安、无聊或被冒犯，
this type of rumination can and will lead to a word, us finding issues where there are none and spending a huge amount of energy and time thinking about interactions that at this stage you just can't change anyways. There was a very interesting meta-analysis on this, so an analysis of a bunch of studies that was published in 2024 in the Journal of Psychiatric Research. And this meta-analysis, it looked at over 35 studies, there were 10,000 participants across these studies. And what it found was that post-event rumination like this often changes our interpretation of an event to be more negative, even if we left feeling positive right afterwards. So our perception changes with time. It's highly
这种反刍思维可以而且会导致一个词，让我们在没有问题的地方发现问题，并花费大量的时间和精力去思考那些在这个阶段你无论如何都无法改变的互动。对此有一个非常有趣的荟萃分析，也就是对一系列研究的分析，发表在2024年的《精神病学研究杂志》上。这项荟萃分析研究了超过35项研究，这些研究中共有10,000名参与者。它发现，像这样的事后反刍往往会改变我们对事件的解读，使其变得更加负面，即使我们在事后离开时感觉很积极。所以我们的感知会随着时间而改变。它与
correlated to increased social anxiety and to people pleasing. So some other final signs of a good girl complex. I just want to mention, I think you may also be very susceptible to staying in relationships way longer than you should. This goes for romantic relationships. naturally, I would say even more so for friendships. Something that I've had to realize is that it's actually not normal to give people as many second chances as I have done. I have forgiven people time and time again for things that I would never have done in the first place, ever. But I think deep down, it comes back to this feeling that, you know, I am secretly a bad person. I'm not a good person. So if I forgive people for their mistakes, when I inevitably make the worst mistake of all,
增加的社交焦虑和讨好他人高度相关。所以“乖乖女情结”还有一些其他的最终迹象。我只想提一下，我认为你可能也非常容易在一段关系中停留的时间比你应该停留的时间长得多。这自然适用于浪漫关系，我会说对于友谊更是如此。我不得不意识到的一件事是，给人们像我给过的那样多的第二次机会实际上是不正常的。我一次又一次地原谅了人们，因为那些我一开始就永远不会做的事情。但我认为在内心深处，它归结为这种感觉，你知道，我私下里是一个坏人。我不是一个好人。所以如果我原谅人们的错误，当我不可避免地犯下所有错误中最严重的错误时，
because I am evil and awful, maybe they'll forgive me. Maybe they'll have forgiveness in their heart for what I've done. Maybe that sounds insane to you. Maybe you can relate. I thought I just put it out there because I do think this is a pattern that a lot of us have. And finally, perhaps the greatest sign can be summarized into one sentence, which is that you're so mature for your age. You've heard this all your life since you were a kid.
因为我很邪恶和糟糕，也许他们会原谅我。也许他们心中会有宽恕，原谅我所做的事情。也许这对你来说听起来很疯狂。也许你能产生共鸣。我想我只是把它说出来，因为我确实认为这是我们许多人都有的一种模式。最后，也许最大的迹象可以用一句话来概括，那就是你“少年老成”。你从小到大一直听到这句话。
All your life. You're so mature. You're so smart. At the time, I think it feels like an amazing compliment. You know, you're being accepted as one of the adults. You're so grown up. But the thing is, when adults think of you as mature, they stop giving you the grace that you should receive as a kid. The kind of grace that is important whilst you are learning and the kind of grace that is important when you don't know better.
你的一生。你太成熟了。你太聪明了。当时，我认为这感觉像是一个了不起的赞美。你知道，你被接受为成年人之一。你太成熟了。但问题是，当成年人认为你成熟时，他们就不再给你作为孩子应该得到的宽容。那种在你学习时很重要的宽容，以及在你不知道更好时很重要的宽容。
And they start too soon, they start assigning adult responsibilities to you, particularly emotional responsibilities that you're just not ready for yet. you shouldn't have to be ready for. A kind of comorbidity to being a good girl is often being prerentified or made to take care of your family way earlier than as usual. We can also see how this has ties to being the eldest daughter as well. It's all connected. As children, you should be free to express how you feel openly and loudly, rather than through the lens of what we think adults would like from us. That is one of the best parts about being a kid. And when you don't have that freedom, because somebody has started to see you as this good girl, this good kid, this mature kid, you lose out. You become a mature version of yourself much earlier on. And we know this impacts
他们开始得太早了，他们开始把成人的责任分配给你，特别是你还没准备好承担的情绪责任。你不应该不得不准备好。作为乖女孩的一种共病通常是“亲职化”，或者被迫比平时更早地照顾你的家庭。我们也可以看到这与作为长女之间的联系。这一切都是相连的。作为孩子，你应该自由地公开、大声地表达你的感受，而不是通过我们认为成年人希望我们表现出的那种视角。那是作为孩子最好的部分之一。当你没有那种自由时，因为有人开始把你视为这个乖女孩、这个乖孩子、这个成熟的孩子，你就输了。你更早地成为了成熟版本的自己。我们知道这会影响
women and girls a whole lot more. Research including a 1993 paper published in the Harvard Educational Review shows that young girls often speak their minds quite freely during early childhood it's something that we call ordinary courage, they stop much sooner than boys. The researcher who did this study, her name is Annie Rogers, she calls this the loss of voice. The consequence of this loss of voice early on can be severe. In 2011, there was a very groundbreaking matter analysis by a well-known researcher. Her name is Dana, Dana Crowley, Jack. And she basically found that an increase in self-silancing amongst women and girls
女性和女孩的程度要大得多。包括1993年发表在《哈佛教育评论》上的一篇论文在内的研究表明，年轻女孩在童年早期经常相当自由地表达自己的想法，这被称为“普通勇气”，她们比男孩更早停止这样做。进行这项研究的研究员，她的名字叫Annie Rogers，她称之为“声音的丧失”。这种早期声音丧失的后果可能是严重的。2011年，一位知名研究员进行了一项非常开创性的荟萃分析。她的名字叫Dana，Dana Crowley Jack。她基本上发现，女性和女孩中自我沉默的增加
was correlated with increased depression and increased psychological vulnerability later in life. Women suffer under the silent burden that they have been asked to carry since they were children. And they suffer under the silent burden of everybody else's happiness that they feel responsible for. So how does this happen and how do we break out of it? We're going to talk about that and so much more after this short break. Stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids lunches. is there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pesto survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.com for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Every case has a story.
与后来生活中抑郁症和心理脆弱性的增加相关。女性承受着她们自童年起就被要求背负的沉默负担。她们承受着她们觉得有责任承担的每个人的幸福的沉默负担。那么这是如何发生的，我们如何打破它呢？在短暂休息后，我们将讨论这个问题以及更多内容。请留下来。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？香蒜酱能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动付款优惠。访问bell.com了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。每个案件都有一个故事。
victim has a voice, but will it be heard? I'm Nancy Grace on crime stories. We go beyond headlines to examine evidence, challenge the story we're fed, and pursue justice for victims and their families. Please join us at Crime Stories with Nancy Grace on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you find your podcasts. Hope you join us. I'll see you there, friend. Welcome aboard Season 6 of The Girlfriends, Flight or Fight, which takes place 30,000 feet in the sky. There's great food, comfortable chairs, and attentive stewardesses. The stewardesses were so beautiful. But in reality, the stewardess job is far less glamorous than it appears.
受害者有发言权，但会被听到吗？我是Nancy Grace，在《犯罪故事》中。我们超越头条新闻去审视证据，挑战我们被灌输的故事，并为受害者及其家人寻求正义。请加入我们在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你找到播客的任何地方收听《Nancy Grace的犯罪故事》。希望你加入我们。朋友，到时见。欢迎登上《女朋友》第6季，《飞行或战斗》，故事发生在30,000英尺的高空。那里有很棒的食物、舒适的椅子和细心的空姐。空姐们太漂亮了。但实际上，空姐的工作远没有看起来那么迷人。
It was the most sexist job I think you could have. In this era, the airlines told these stewardesses, they have to be single. They had no good excuse for why they wouldn't let women be married. They have to be skinny. We were starving ourselves. And they have to be young. You would retire at age 32. But one day, a group of stewardesses said, this has got to stop. They risked it all, turning a fight for fairness into a revolution. Listen to the girlfriends, flight or fight. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Robert Lamb.
我认为这是你能拥有的最性别歧视的工作。在那个时代，航空公司告诉这些空姐，她们必须单身。对于为什么不允许女性结婚，她们没有好的借口。她们必须苗条。我们当时在挨饿。而且她们必须年轻。你会在32岁时退休。但有一天，一群空姐说，这必须停止。她们冒了一切风险，将一场争取公平的斗争变成了一场革命。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友，飞行或战斗》。嘿，我是Robert Lamb。
And this is Joe McCormick, and we're the hosts of the Stuff to Blow Your Mind podcast. This week on the show, it's Star Trek. So we're going to be talking about the Borg all week long. Are you ready to get some probes put in your flesh? That's right. Tune in. Resistance is futile. We're going to talk science, the culture of the Borg, various interpretations, and we're going to talk about Star Trek First Contact on Weird House Cinema on Friday.
我是Joe McCormick，我们是《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》播客的主持人。本周节目是《星际迷航》。所以我们整周都会讨论博格人。你准备好让一些探测器进入你的肉体了吗？没错。收听吧。抵抗是徒劳的。我们将讨论科学、博格文化、各种解读，我们将在周五的《怪异电影院》中讨论《星际迷航：第一次接触》。
Listen to stuff to blow your mind on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. Our books are being banned, scanned by AI, and destroyed. I'm Jack We're Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Blacklit podcast, we're outside asking some of the custodians of our stories, teachers, and our modern day writers, why? They don't want a whole bunch of little elevators, Michael Maxes, and Martin Luther King's, right? They want to build children who have no empathy. That's really the ultimate goal. We want books that don't make white kids feel bad.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》。是否存在一种针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是针对黑人文学。我们的书正在被禁、被人工智能扫描并销毁。我是Jack We're Peace Thomas，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们走出去询问我们故事的一些保管人、老师和我们现代的作家，为什么？他们不想要一大堆小埃尔维斯、马尔科姆·X和马丁·路德·金，对吧？他们想培养没有同理心的孩子。这才是最终的目标。我们想要那些不会让白人孩子感到难过的书。
So is the war on literacy and information or our ability to connect? We want people to know how sexy reading is and how fun they could be and not always associated with education. It could be an escape. It could be entertainment. And that is the beauty of reading. It can be all of those things. And considering this is Black Reading Month,
所以，这是对识字和信息的战争，还是对我们建立联系能力的战争？我们希望人们知道阅读是多么性感，它可能有多么有趣，而不是总是与教育联系在一起。它可以是一种逃避。它可以是娱乐。这就是阅读的美妙之处。它可以是所有这些事情。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，
The only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So why do people develop Good Girl Syndrome in the first place? Well, like merely literally every single psychological concept, it comes back to experiences in our childhood. Of course, gender socialization is critical here, especially when my children. I think we've explored that already. On a more psychological level, it also comes down to how we experience love and how girls experience love differently to boys.
唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。那么为什么人们首先会发展出“乖乖女综合症”呢？好吧，就像几乎每一个心理学概念一样，它归结为我们童年的经历。当然，性别社会化在这里至关重要，尤其是当我是孩子的时候。我想我们已经探讨过这一点了。在更心理学的层面上，它也归结为我们如何体验爱，以及女孩体验爱的方式与男孩有何不同。
If we experience love, parental love, is something that was conditional and tied to being helpful, quiet, agreeable, high achieving, we pursue those parts of ourselves and we learn to shut down the parts of ourselves that don't result in that feeling and don't result in love, which is the messy, angry, needy parts of us that, you know, might bring about shame or a lack of affection. As a child, this works quite well as a strategy to get love. But as good girl syndrome and good girl traits become internalized, it can almost feel like this is who we've always been. And we confuse what is basically a peacemaking strategy with our personality. And we start to think, you know, it's actually not that bad to put others first, which is maybe correct.
如果我们体验到的爱，父母的爱，是有条件的，并且与乐于助人、安静、随和、高成就联系在一起，我们就会追求我们自己的那些部分，并学会关闭我们自己那些不会导致那种感觉、不会导致爱的部分，也就是我们身上混乱、愤怒、需要关怀的部分，你知道，这可能会带来羞耻感或缺乏感情。作为一个孩子，这作为获得爱的策略非常有效。但随着“乖乖女综合症”和乖乖女特质变得内化，它几乎感觉这就是我们一直以来的样子。我们将基本上是一种维持和平的策略与我们的人格混淆了。我们开始想，你知道，把别人放在第一位其实并不坏，这也许是对的。
But then we think, well, maybe it's not that bad to be miserable so that other people can be happy. And then we start to think, maybe this is who I am. I'm a nice person. I give. I'm giving. And so why change this? Why change these parts of myself, even if they kind of hurt me? I think it's really important to say is, well, this isn't always a choice. This often keeps us safe and accepted. and as a child, that is our ultimate goal. At this point in our lives, belonging is all that we really care about. But one way that this response also shows up that shows that this is more survival than anything else is, is through the forning response. You've likely heard of fight, flight or freeze, I'm pretty sure you have.
但随后我们想，好吧，也许为了让别人快乐而让自己痛苦并不坏。然后我们开始想，也许这就是我。我是一个好人。我给予。我乐于奉献。那么为什么要改变这一点呢？为什么要改变我自己的这些部分，即使它们有点伤害我？我认为非常重要的一点是，好吧，这并不总是一个选择。这通常能让我们保持安全和被接受。作为一个孩子，那是我们的最终目标。在我们人生的这一点上，归属感是我们真正关心的全部。但这种反应表现出来的另一种方式，表明这更多是生存而非其他任何东西，是通过“讨好反应”。你可能听说过“战斗、逃跑或僵住”，我很确定你听说过。
Forning is the silent fourth response that primarily impacts women and people who've experienced trauma or people who hold less power in society. Forning was first identified by the psychotherapist's name as Peter Walker in this book he wrote. And this book came out in 2013. It was on complex PTSD. And in the book, he essentially says, if you can't escape a threat and you can't fight a threat or you can't wait out a threat, you will become something that the threat likes. And you will therefore hope that the threat will be nice to you. Forning can include people pleasing.
“讨好”是沉默的第四种反应，主要影响女性和经历过创伤的人，或在社会中拥有较少权力的人。讨好反应最初是由心理治疗师Peter Walker在他写的一本书中确定的。这本书出版于2013年。它是关于复杂性创伤后应激障碍（C-PTSD）的。在书中，他基本上说，如果你无法逃避威胁，你无法对抗威胁，或者你无法等待威胁过去，你就会变成威胁喜欢的东西。因此，你希望威胁会对你友善。讨好可以包括讨好他人。
It can include chronic apologizing, conflict avoidance, excessive caretaking, emotional attunement to others at the expense of ourselves overagreying. I feel like that's basically good girl syndrome and good girl complex in just fewer words. They are incredibly tired. Good girl syndrome and forning as a survival response are intrinsically linked. What's particularly interesting for me is something that I said before, which is that as we get older, it can become harder and harder to differentiate between which parts of our character are shaped by good girl syndrome and this compulsive desire to be liked, and which parts of this is actually just who we are and is just a genuine part of our personality. It becomes indistinguishable. The truth is, is that perhaps on
它可以包括长期道歉、回避冲突、过度照顾、以牺牲自己为代价对他人的情绪进行调适、过度同意。我觉得这基本上就是用更少的词来形容“乖乖女综合症”和“乖乖女情结”。她们非常疲惫。“乖乖女综合症”和作为生存反应的讨好是内在联系在一起的。对我来说特别有趣的是我之前说过的一件事，那就是随着我们年龄的增长，区分哪些性格部分是由“乖乖女综合症”和这种被喜欢的强迫性欲望塑造的，以及哪些部分实际上只是我们自己，只是我们人格中真正的一部分，变得越来越难。它变得无法区分。事实是，也许在
some level, like, we might just never know. We might just never know because at some point we stop thinking, you know, I'm doing this because I want to be loved, or I'm doing this because a parent or teacher conditioned me, or I'm doing this because I get praise, and we just start thinking, I'm doing this. I'm putting other people first because I'm generous and this is who I am, and we're proud of this part of ourselves. Psychologists have a name for this. It's called self-concept integration. In the case of good girl complex, behaviors like the ones we described, that were once strategies for gaining approval become so woven into our identity that to undo them would be to undo who we are. A woman who refuses to say no might not see that as people pleasing.
某种程度上，我们可能永远不会知道。我们可能永远不会知道，因为在某个时刻，我们不再想，你知道，我这样做是因为我想被爱，或者我这样做是因为父母或老师对我进行了条件反射，或者我这样做是因为我得到了赞美，我们只是开始想，我这样做。我把别人放在第一位是因为我很慷慨，这就是我，我们为自己的这一部分感到自豪。心理学家对此有一个名字。它被称为“自我概念整合”。在“乖乖女情结”的情况下，像我们描述的那样曾经是获得认可的策略的行为，变得如此融入我们的身份，以至于撤销它们就等于撤销我们是谁。一个拒绝说“不”的女性可能不会认为那是讨好他人。
She is just somebody who is a nice person. Somebody who anticipates the needs of others that are just really thoughtful, they're empathetic, rather than being hypervigilant. We don't want to pathologize these parts of who we are. In a 2006 study published this year, researchers surveyed, 366 women using this newly developed Good Girl Syndrome questionnaire. And they found that what we call Good Girl Syndrome wasn't just one trait. So it's difficult to identify, but it's a cluster of behaviours that is centred around conditional self-worth and only feeling valuable when you meet other people's expectations. Women who scored highly on this questionnaire also tended to be, A, perfectionist, B, self-sacrificing, C, afraid of making mistakes.
她只是一个好人。一个预见他人需求的人，他们真的很体贴，他们很有同理心，而不是过度警觉。我们不想将我们自己的这些部分病理化。在2024年发表的一项研究中，研究人员使用这种新开发的“乖乖女综合症”问卷调查了366名女性。他们发现我们所说的“乖乖女综合症”不仅仅是一种特质。所以它很难识别，但它是一组以有条件的自我价值为中心的行为，只有当你满足他人的期望时才感到有价值。在这个问卷中得分高的女性也倾向于：A，完美主义者；B，自我牺牲；C，害怕犯错。
What am I up to? D, highly ambitious and very focused on making other people happy. The thing is, these traits make you very likable. They make you really successful. And that is a good feeling. It is a good feeling. But it does have a cost. So let's talk about it.
我讲到哪了？D，雄心勃勃，非常专注于让别人快乐。问题是，这些特质让你非常讨人喜欢。它们让你非常成功。这是一种很好的感觉。这是一种很好的感觉。但它确实有代价。所以让我们谈谈它。
The thing is, this type of over-responsibility we're experiencing, to be completely honest with you, is just a fancy form of emotional suppression. There is this big iron gate that we've established to lock away our true feelings because our true feelings would often stand in opposition of what others want us to do and that is bad. And that is emotional suppression. You may know this already, but long-term people pleasing is being increasingly linked to physical health conditions, increasingly linked to psychological conditions, increasingly linked to things like autoimmune diseases. A study from 2020 showed that autoimmune diseases disproportionately
问题是，我们正在经历的这种过度责任感，对你完全诚实地说，只是一种花哨的情绪压抑形式。我们建立了一道巨大的铁门来锁住我们真实的感受，因为我们真实的感受往往会与别人希望我们做的事情背道而驰，那是坏的。这就是情绪压抑。你可能已经知道了，但长期的讨好他人正越来越多地与身体健康状况联系在一起，越来越多地与心理状况联系在一起，越来越多地与自身免疫性疾病等事物联系在一起。2020年的一项研究表明，自身免疫性疾病不成比例地
affect women in around 80% of cases 8-0. And they often emerge after periods of significant stress and self-silencing. A good example of this is traumatic pregnancies or things where they've at times when they've experienced healthcare trauma. There's a health psychologist named is Dr. Sula Winskison and she's looked into this more specifically. And she's looked into this more specifically. And she's looked into the impact of suppressing our emotions upon our bodies more specifically. And she notes that suppression is one of the most depleting cognitive responses. It activates these higher-order brain regions like the prefrontal cortex, which decrease activation in self-emotion processing centers like the amygdala.
影响女性，约占80%的病例。它们通常出现在经历重大压力和自我沉默的时期之后。这方面的一个好例子是创伤性怀孕或她们在经历医疗创伤时的情况。有一位健康心理学家名叫Sula Winskison博士，她更具体地研究了这一点。她更具体地研究了这一点。她更具体地研究了压抑情绪对我们身体的影响。她指出，压抑是最消耗认知的反应之一。它激活了前额叶皮层等高级大脑区域，这降低了杏仁核等自我情绪处理中心的激活。
This leads to increased cortisol secretion. It leads to increase adrenaline, and that can all disrupt immune system functioning, hence the rise of autoimmune diseases. There's still so much research that is ongoing in the space, so much that it's probably going to come out in the next couple of years, but I find it so shocking that being a good girl looks so neat and tidy from the outside, it looks so pretty, but it is wrecking our bodies from the inside out, all for the comfort and peace of others.
这会导致皮质醇分泌增加。它会导致肾上腺素增加，而这一切都会破坏免疫系统的功能，因此自身免疫性疾病才会增多。在这个领域仍有大量的研究正在进行，未来几年可能会有大量成果问世，但我感到非常震惊的是，“乖乖女”从外表看是那么整洁、那么漂亮，但它却在从内到外摧毁我们的身体，而这一切仅仅是为了他人的舒适与安宁。
Beyond the physical impact, the psychological impact, the immune system impact, there is also a professional cost and a financial cost, a literal monetary cost to being a good girl. One of the most significant costs of this complex is that being liked sometimes seems incompatible with taking up space and taking up space is often required in this society to get ahead, to increase your surface area for luck and to access opportunities. If you are constantly trying not to inconvenience anyone, there is a lot of things. things that you won't do. You won't pitch the idea. You won't ask for a raise. You probably won't take credit for your own work. You probably won't call out bad behavior. You probably won't apply for
除了生理影响、心理影响和免疫系统影响外，做一个“乖乖女”还有职业代价和经济代价，甚至是实实在在的金钱代价。这种情结最显著的代价之一是，讨人喜欢有时似乎与占据空间不兼容，而在这个社会中，想要出人头地、增加运气覆盖面并获得机会，往往需要占据空间。如果你总是试图不给任何人添麻烦，那么有很多事情你都不会去做。你不会提出想法，不会要求加薪，可能不会为自己的工作争取功劳，可能不会指出不良行为，可能不会申请
jobs that you maybe don't think that you're qualified for. Now, over a lifetime, this stacks up in a way that is immeasurable, missed opportunities that could have changed your life, raises, money, promotions, risks that could have opened entirely new doors, but also missed friendships and missed relationships and crucially a missed relationship with who you really are, which is the most critical of all. So the next kind of question to ask is how do we go about challenging this, especially when good girl syndrome feels like a friend and feels like it's getting you somewhere. I'm going to talk about four strategies here. They are number one, remembering that you are an adult and that you're not in trouble. Number two, the importance of vicarious modeling.
那些你可能认为自己不够格的工作。长此以往，这会以一种无法估量的方式累积起来：错失了本可以改变你人生的机会、加薪、金钱、晋升、本可以开启全新大门的冒险，但也错失了友谊和人际关系，最关键的是，错失了与真实自我的关系，而这才是最重要的一点。所以，下一个要问的问题是，我们该如何挑战这种心态，尤其是当“乖乖女综合症”感觉像个朋友，并且感觉它正在让你有所成就时。我在这里要谈谈四种策略。第一，记住你是一个成年人，你并没有惹麻烦。第二，替代性建模的重要性。
number three, the hidden power of being ugly, which I will explain a little bit more, but I think is very crucial here. And number four, letting others feel responsible for their own emotions, even when it feels uncomfortable, which is critical to this. So let's start at the very top of this list. Number one, remember that you are an adult. You are not a child. You are not somebody's inferior. No one is more important than you. Nobody is more important than anybody else. You have just as much right to speak your mind, to ask for what you want, and to have opinions as anybody else, even if that doesn't feel natural. And most importantly, once again, you're not in trouble. Nobody is mad at you. I don't know if you felt this way, but for most of my adult life,
第三，变“丑”的隐藏力量，我会稍作解释，但我认为这在这里非常关键。第四，让别人为自己的情绪负责，即使这让人感到不舒服，这对这一点至关重要。那么，让我们从这个列表的最顶端开始。第一，记住你是一个成年人。你不是孩子，也不是谁的下属。没有人比你更重要，没有人比任何人更重要。你有权表达自己的想法、要求自己想要的东西并拥有自己的观点，就像其他人一样，即使这感觉并不自然。最重要的是，再说一次，你没有惹麻烦。没有人对你生气。我不知道你是否有过这种感觉，但在我成年后的大部分时间里，
I have felt like at any moment someone is going to turn around and be like, bad girl. they're going to turn around and be like, you are very disappointing. You're in big, big trouble. Like, watch out. We've been watching you. We know what you've done. We've been watching you this whole time. I even have dreams about it sometimes. I have dreams where like somebody is scolding me or telling me off. That is good girl syndrome. Right there. What this really is is an anticipation that you will be shamed. And as a good girl, shame is one of the worst things that you can feel. The sense that you've disappointed somebody is so terrible. but also nobody can make you feel ashamed for something that you have no issue with personally.
我总觉得随时会有人转过身来说：“坏女孩”。他们会转过身来说：“你太让人失望了。你惹了大麻烦了。小心点。我们一直在盯着你。我们知道你做了什么。我们一直都在盯着你。”我有时甚至会做关于这个的梦。我梦见有人在责骂我或训斥我。这就是“乖乖女综合症”。这实际上是对被羞辱的预期。作为一个“乖乖女”，羞耻感是你所能感受到的最糟糕的事情之一。那种让某人失望的感觉太可怕了。但同时，如果某件事你个人觉得没问题，没人能让你感到羞耻。
That's the secret psychological hack within this all. If I walked up to you and I said, aren't you ashamed to be wearing that shirt? Or aren't you ashamed that you acted that way? You might have a moment where you hesitate and you self-doubt and you look at your shirt and you think back on your actions and you're like, my God, have I done something wrong? But if you assessed your outfit and you assessed your behavior
这就是这一切背后的心理秘诀。如果我走到你面前说：“你穿着那件衬衫不觉得羞耻吗？”或者“你那样做不觉得羞耻吗？”你可能会有一瞬间的犹豫和自我怀疑，你会看看自己的衬衫，回想自己的行为，然后心想：“天哪，我做错什么了吗？”但如果你评估了自己的着装和行为，
and you personally found nothing wrong with it. No, you wouldn't feel ashamed. You wouldn't feel ashamed because by your own standards, you haven't done anything wrong. You probably look at me like I had a few things going on in my own head. Your shame around asking for what you want or putting yourself first is equally up to your own interpretation. What is so bad about actually putting your needs first?
并且你个人觉得没什么问题。不，你不会感到羞耻。你不会感到羞耻，因为按照你自己的标准，你没有做错任何事。你可能会觉得我脑子有问题。你对于要求自己想要的东西或把自己放在首位所感到的羞耻，同样取决于你自己的解读。真正把自己的需求放在首位有什么不好呢？
What is shameful about that? What is so shameful about disappointing somebody? Because otherwise you would be disappointed. You're both equals. What is so bad about saying, I'm actually not happy with that. You are an adult, they're an adult. They can fucking deal with it. Sorry to swear, but they can deal with it.
那有什么可耻的？让某人失望有什么可耻的？因为如果不这样做，失望的就是你自己。你们是平等的。说“我其实对那个不满意”有什么不好？你是成年人，他们也是成年人。他们完全可以自己处理。抱歉说了脏话，但他们可以处理好。
They're not your master. You are not their mother. You are both people who deserve equal respect. So be kind, be respectful, but don't be a martyr. And don't martyr yourself because you think somebody else's disappointment it automatically means that you've done something morally wrong. It benefits them to make you feel that way. This is such an important distinction to make, maybe the most crucial.
他们不是你的主人，你也不是他们的母亲。你们都是值得平等尊重的人。所以要友善，要尊重，但不要做烈士。不要因为觉得别人的失望就自动意味着你在道德上做错了什么而牺牲自己。让他们觉得你那样做对他们有利。这是一个非常重要的区别，也许是最关键的区别。
Someone being unhappy with your decision is not the same thing as your decision being bad or being wrong. Someone being annoyed with you is not evidence that you are a horrible person. They have ownership over their reaction. It's okay. Like just repeat after me, I'm not. in any trouble. I'm an adult. They're an adult. They can deal with it. Number two, you need a role model who is the antithesis of a good girl. You need a woman who you really respect and who you admire who doesn't have anything to do with a good girl complex. So why is this so critical? Two words,
别人对你的决定不满意，并不等同于你的决定很糟糕或错误。别人对你感到恼火，也不是你是坏人的证据。他们要为自己的反应负责。没关系。就像我一样跟着重复：我没有惹任何麻烦。我是成年人。他们是成年人。他们可以处理好。第二，你需要一个与“乖乖女”截然相反的榜样。你需要一个你真正尊重和钦佩的女性，她与“乖乖女”情结毫无关系。那么为什么这如此关键？两个词：
vicarious modeling. If you are not at the stage yet of being able to retire your former good girl self, if it feels safe to you, the best next thing you can do is to see examples of women who have retired their good girl self and the world has kept turning if not gotten better for them. Vicarious modeling was first studied by probably one of the most famous men in psychology. If you've done a psychology course, you've heard his name, Albert Bundura. And he essentially realized that a lot of how we learn and change behavior is by watching. when we see someone do things that we wish we could do or that we wish we were capable of, our sense of possibility, even like neurologically and psychologically,
替代性建模。如果你还没有达到能够退休你那“乖乖女”自我的阶段，如果这让你感到安全，那么你能做的最好的下一步就是看看那些已经退休了“乖乖女”自我的女性的例子，看看世界依然在运转，甚至对她们来说变得更好了。替代性建模最初是由心理学界最著名的人物之一研究的。如果你上过心理学课程，你一定听过他的名字，阿尔伯特·班杜拉。他本质上意识到，我们学习和改变行为的很大一部分是通过观察。当我们看到别人做我们希望自己能做或希望自己有能力做的事情时，我们的可能性感，甚至在神经学和心理学上，
immediately expands. This is particularly important with good girl syndrome or a good girl complex because so much of it is built on these predictions about what is going to happen if I stop being good. And there is this expectation that if I'm not good, people won't like me, people won't be happy with me. I won't be happy. I'm going to lose everything. I'm going to be miserable. I'm going to lose relationships opportunities. Maybe. But a role model gives your brain contradictory alternative evidence. You watch a woman say no without providing a full five-minute explanation and you realize nothing happened. You watch a woman be vocal. Disagree openly
都会立即扩展。这在“乖乖女综合症”或“乖乖女情结”中尤为重要，因为其中很大一部分是建立在对“如果我不再做一个好女孩会发生什么”的预测之上的。人们有一种期望：如果我不够好，人们就不会喜欢我，人们就不会对我满意。我不会快乐。我会失去一切。我会变得痛苦。我会失去人际关系和机会。也许吧。但榜样会给你的大脑提供矛盾的替代证据。你看着一个女性在不提供五分钟完整解释的情况下说“不”，你意识到什么都没发生。你看着一个女性公开表达意见，公开与人产生分歧，
with people and people still respect her and maybe they don't and she just doesn't care. Perhaps there are some consequences, but there is so much that she has gained from that. And so the catastrophe that you have been anticipating doesn't seem to emerge the way that you think it would. I also think, just to add to this, you need examples of women who don't just demonstrate that you don't have to be good all the time. You specifically need examples of women who show that being good and being a good person and not the same thing. A good girl is obedient, agreeable, convenient. She's is easy to approve of, a good person can be none of that and still be deeply kind and still be deeply generous and still be loved by other people. Being good and being a good girl, not the same thing.
而人们依然尊重她，也许他们不尊重，但她根本不在乎。也许会有一些后果，但她从中获得了太多。所以你一直预期的灾难似乎并没有像你想象的那样出现。我还认为，补充一点，你需要那些不仅证明你不必一直做一个好女孩的女性例子。你特别需要那些证明“做一个好女孩”和“做一个好人”不是一回事的女性例子。乖乖女是顺从的、讨喜的、方便的。她很容易获得认可，而一个好人可以完全不是那样，但依然可以非常善良、非常慷慨，并被他人深爱。做一个好人与做一个乖乖女，不是一回事。
Whether it's someone you know, like maybe not, it could be a celebrity, could be a woman of history, could be an author. Honestly, this might be controversial. Like, your model could literally be a man who has the ego and confidence that you want. Just have someone in mind as an icon or an example for you essentially as a role model that, you know, if they can do it, why can't I? How would they behave in this situation? How would they treat this event or this moment where I feel like I have to be good? Would they be good the way that I think that I need to be? Okay, we need to take one more short break, but when we return, let's talk about the psychological benefits of being ugly and embracing your ugliness as a good girl and how to leave others to have their own emotional response.
无论那个人是你认识的人，也许不是，可能是名人，可能是历史上的女性，可能是作家。老实说，这可能会引起争议。你的榜样甚至可以是一个拥有你想要的自我和自信的男性。本质上，只要心中有一个偶像或例子作为榜样，你知道，如果他们能做到，为什么我不能？在这种情况下他们会怎么做？他们会如何对待这个让我觉得必须表现得“好”的事件或时刻？他们会像我以为我需要的那样表现得“好”吗？好了，我们需要再休息一下，但回来后，让我们谈谈变“丑”的心理益处，以及作为一个乖乖女如何拥抱你的“丑陋”，以及如何让别人去承担他们自己的情绪反应，
especially when that response is, some would say, uncomfortable. So stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month.
尤其是当这种反应，有些人会说，让人不舒服的时候。所以请留下来。在每个为孩子们准备午餐的夜晚背后，都有很多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切完黄瓜之前，你能看完第8集吗？获取贝尔纯光纤互联网，包含Craved Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。
Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Every case has a story. Every victim has a voice, but will it be heard? I'm Nancy Grace. On crime stories, we go beyond headlines to examine evidence, challenge the story we're fed, and pursue justice for victims and their families. Please join us at crime stories. with Nancy Grace on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you find your podcasts. Hope you join us. I'll see you there, friend.
互联网价格保证两年，两年合约并有自动支付优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询可用性。贝尔，连接就是一切。每个案件都有一个故事。每个受害者都有一个声音，但它会被听到吗？我是南希·格蕾丝。在《犯罪故事》中，我们超越头条新闻，审视证据，挑战我们被灌输的故事，并为受害者及其家人追求正义。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方加入我们的《南希·格蕾丝犯罪故事》。希望你能加入我们。朋友，到时见。
Welcome aboard Season 6 of The Girlfriends, Flight or Fight, which takes place 30,000 feet in the sky. There's great food, comfortable chairs, and attentive stewardesses. The stewardesses were so beautiful. But in reality, the stewardess job is far less glamorous. than it appears. It was the most sexist job I think you could have. In this era, the airlines told these stewardesses, they have to be single.
欢迎来到《女朋友们》第6季，“飞行或战斗”，故事发生在3万英尺的高空。那里有美味的食物、舒适的椅子和细心的空姐。空姐们太漂亮了。但实际上，空姐的工作远没有看起来那么光鲜亮丽。我认为这是你能拥有的最性别歧视的工作。在那个时代，航空公司告诉这些空姐，她们必须单身。
They had no good excuse for why they wouldn't let women be married. They have to be skinny. We were starving ourselves. And they have to be young. You would retire at age 32. But one day, a group of stewardesses said, this has got to stop. They risked it all,
她们对于为什么不允许女性结婚没有任何正当理由。她们必须苗条。我们当时在挨饿。而且她们必须年轻。你32岁就得退休。但有一天，一群空姐说，这一切必须停止。她们冒着一切风险，
turning a fight for fairness into a revolution. Listen to the girlfriends, flight or fight, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Robert Lamb.
将一场争取公平的斗争变成了一场革命。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《女朋友们：飞行或战斗》。嘿，我是罗伯特·兰姆。
And this is Joe McCormick, and we're the hosts of the Stuff to Blow Your Mind podcast. This week on the show, it's Star Trek. So we're going to be talking about the Borg all week long. Are you ready to get some
我是乔·麦考密克，我们是《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》播客的主持人。本周节目主题是《星际迷航》。所以我们整周都会讨论博格人。你准备好让一些
probes put in your flesh. That's right. Tune in. Resistance is futile. We're going to talk science, the culture of the board, various interpretations, and we're going to talk about Star Trek First Contact on Weird House Cinema on Friday. Listen to stuff to blow your mind on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, here's the thing I'm speaking with more artists, policymakers, and performers like actor Stephen Root. I think for me to be any good or for any character, act to be any good. You've got to put enough of yourself and your empathy for people in it. I'm a people watcher.
探测器植入你的肉体了吗？没错。敬请收听。抵抗是徒劳的。我们将讨论科学、博格文化、各种解读，我们还将在周五的《怪异电影院》中讨论《星际迷航：第一类接触》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》。嗨，我是亚历克·鲍德温。本季在我的播客《Here's the Thing》中，我将与更多艺术家、政策制定者和表演者交谈，比如演员斯蒂芬·鲁特。我认为对我来说，要表现得好，或者任何角色要表现得好，你必须投入足够的自我和对他人的同理心。我是一个观察者。
You see that guy going down the dream? Yeah, I can use that. Open Igloo co-founder, Alia Mohamed. I love staying on top of what is going on in our city. What is going on in city politics? What is on renter's minds? And taking all of that knowledge to build a platform that hopefully is going to make New York City better in the long run.
你看到那个走在街上的人了吗？是的，我可以利用这一点。Open Igloo联合创始人阿利亚·穆罕默德。我喜欢掌握我们城市正在发生的事情。城市政治在发生什么？租客们在想什么？并利用所有这些知识来建立一个平台，希望从长远来看能让纽约市变得更好。
And actress and singer Melissa Eriko. Partnership took on a whole, meaning when I started making my own work. It's like you with a great actress or actor. It was best to come out of your trailer, full of life, and just face another person who's full of life and don't talk. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
还有女演员兼歌手梅丽莎·埃里科。当我开始制作自己的作品时，合作有了全新的意义。就像你和一位伟大的女演员或男演员在一起一样。最好是充满活力地走出你的拖车，面对另一个充满活力的人，不要说话。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Here's the Thing》。
So I want to talk about this truly remarkable article that I read the other day from the Atlantic. And the article was titled The Incredible Freedom of Not Trying to Love look good. In this article, the author is basically saying, I'm an ugly person and being ugly has made me invisible in ways that have allowed me to do things and try things and work at things that I otherwise maybe would not have been able to do if I was preoccupied with being attractive or other people were preoccupied with my looks. Being a good girl and being an attractive girl often go hand in hand. Not always, but a lot of the time. Just like gendered behavior is really tied up in morality, so is beauty and looks. Just like being a good girl is tied up in conformity,
所以我想谈谈我前几天在大西洋月刊上读到的一篇非常了不起的文章。文章标题是《不试图看起来好看的不可思议的自由》。在这篇文章中，作者基本上是在说，我是一个丑陋的人，而变丑让我以某种方式变得隐形，这让我能够做一些事情、尝试一些事情并从事一些事情，如果我当时沉迷于变得有吸引力，或者其他人沉迷于我的外表，我可能就无法做到这些。做一个乖乖女和做一个有吸引力的女孩往往是相辅相成的。不总是这样，但很多时候是这样。就像性别化的行为与道德紧密相连一样，美貌和外表也是如此。就像做一个乖乖女与从众紧密相连一样，
so are certain things that we do for our appearance. If being a good girl is all about trying to be pleasing, what's more pleasing than being pretty and nice to look at? You know, if being a good girl means doing things for others, this article basically argues that most appearance-based activities are for others. We can't see ourselves. Our body is just a vessel for our soul. Our appearance is for people beyond us and around us. And our appearance is something that we use to hope that they'll treat us better or based on how we portray ourselves. This is why one possible, not the only way, but one possible way of unlearning your good girl tendencies, is to conduct a little bit of an experiment and just retire some of your beauty routines for a month.
我们为外表所做的一些事情也是如此。如果做一个乖乖女就是为了取悦他人，还有什么比漂亮、好看更令人愉悦的呢？你知道，如果做一个乖乖女意味着为他人做事，这篇文章基本上认为大多数基于外表的活动都是为了他人。我们看不到自己。我们的身体只是灵魂的容器。我们的外表是为了我们之外和周围的人。我们的外表是我们用来希望他们能更好地对待我们，或者基于我们如何塑造自己。这就是为什么学习摆脱乖乖女倾向的一种可能的方法（不是唯一的方法）是进行一个小实验，把你的美容程序停掉一个月。
Just a month. Embrace the power of being a little bit of a mess, not being put together all the time. Go to work without makeup. Go out wearing whatever you want even if it doesn't match. Look sloppy. Look sloppy. Don't cover up your pimple or your acne. Don't get your nails done.
就一个月。拥抱那种有点混乱、不总是整洁的力量。不化妆去上班。穿着任何你想要的衣服出门，即使它们不搭配。看起来邋遢一点。看起来邋遢一点。不要遮盖你的痘痘或痤疮。不要去做指甲。
Don't shave your legs. Just for a month. Now, obviously, important disclaimer, if this makes you happy, keep doing it because then it's about you. But any appointments or any routines or things that you do where you are genuinely like, this is such a time burden. I can't believe I have to go and pay $50 to get my nails done. I can't believe I have to wear makeup when I'm so tired. I need to do this in order for this person to like me or to get ahead of whatever. And yet it inconveniences me. Anything that follows that pattern of thought, take a break. I did this this year.
不要刮腿毛。就一个月。现在，显然，重要的免责声明，如果这让你快乐，那就继续做，因为那样就是为了你自己。但任何预约、任何程序或事情，如果你真心觉得“这真是个时间负担，我不敢相信我必须去花50美元做指甲。我不敢相信我这么累了还得化妆。我需要这样做才能让这个人喜欢我或为了获得什么好处。然而这却给我带来了不便。”任何遵循这种思维模式的事情，都休息一下。我今年就这么做了。
I would always get my eyelashes done. I would always have like, literally every four weeks I would go and sit down and like they would put fake eyelashes on me for like three years I would do this. And I would always have like my full acrylic set of nails and I would fake tan once a week. And I just stopped for a while when I was moving to London. Kind of incidentally I didn't have time. And then I stopped deliberately. And it was very, very free.
我以前总是去做睫毛。我总是，真的每四周我就会去坐下来，他们会给我贴假睫毛，我这样做了三年。我总是做全套亚克力指甲，每周做一次美黑。当我搬到伦敦时，我停了一段时间。有点偶然，我没时间。然后我故意停了下来。这非常、非常自由。
It felt, it just felt so. nice to be a less put-together version of myself and take that time back for me. And my life actually didn't change that much. I think it was this realization, you know, that I don't really owe people attractiveness just because it's nice for them that really occurred because of this. Sure, it's nice for me. And obviously, if you're watching on Netflix, I'm wearing makeup. And obviously, I've curled my hair and I put effort into my appearance and my nice blue top. But I do that for me, I feel like. I used to feel the shame around my, my appearance at times. Like, I used to really feel like if I was ugly or disheveled or, like, didn't put myself together, like, that was a sign of disrespect
感觉，感觉做一个不那么精致的自己真是太好了，并把那些时间拿回来给自己。我的生活其实并没有太大改变。我想正是这种认识，你知道，我并不真的欠别人什么吸引力，仅仅因为这对他们来说很好，这确实是因为这个原因才发生的。当然，这对我来说很好。显然，如果你在Netflix上观看，我化了妆。显然，我卷了头发，我在外表和漂亮的蓝色上衣上花了很多心思。但我感觉我是为了自己才这么做的。我过去有时会因为我的外表感到羞耻。就像，我过去真的觉得如果我很丑、衣衫不整，或者没有打扮自己，那是一种不尊重
to somebody else and I was letting them down. I still feel that way sometimes. But I think that unlearning that has also meant, like, gaining back freedom and time that I wanted for me, especially these days when we're facing the skinny apocalypse, as they call it, and everyone is getting smaller and smaller and smaller. And, you know, the presence of the body positivity, movement has kind of somewhat been drowned out, I really think it's important to question, what do I really owe people when it comes to my body and my looks? Do I actually owe them fucking anything? And how may I be trying to fit the good girl mold through my appearance? You might not totally agree with that. It might not be completely relevant for you,
对别人，我让他们失望了。我有时仍然有这种感觉。但我认为摆脱这种心态也意味着，赢回了我想要的自由和时间，尤其是在这些天我们面临所谓的“瘦身启示录”时，每个人都变得越来越小。而且，你知道，身体积极性运动的存在在某种程度上被淹没了，我真的认为质疑“当涉及到我的身体和外表时，我到底欠别人什么？”很重要。我真的欠他们什么吗？我可能正试图通过我的外表来适应乖乖女的模子？你可能并不完全同意这一点。它可能对你来说不完全相关，
but I do think that that article was interesting and I do think it's an interesting correlation between being a good girl, a polite girl, a nice girl, and being an attractive, pretty girl who does certain things based on how others want her to look. So the final thing that we can take from the literature on overcoming good girl syndrome is the most critical, which is to let others sit in their own discomfort rather than trying to fix their feelings. I just think in general we need to start letting people be responsible for their own emotions. And we kind of need to trust that they have the skills to deal with being disappointed and annoyed and unhappy. And if they don't have the skills yet, well, I don't think you're helping them by preventing them from learning them so late in
但我确实认为那篇文章很有趣，而且我认为在做一个乖乖女、一个礼貌的女孩、一个好女孩，与做一个基于他人希望她看起来如何而做某些事情的有吸引力的漂亮女孩之间，存在着一种有趣的关联。所以，我们可以从克服乖乖女综合症的文献中得出的最后一点是最关键的，那就是让别人坐在他们自己的不适中，而不是试图修复他们的感受。我只是认为总的来说，我们需要开始让人们为自己的情绪负责。我们需要相信他们有能力处理失望、恼火和不快乐。如果他们还没有这些技能，嗯，我不认为通过阻止他们学习这些技能，你是在帮助他们，
life. You know, somebody being inconvenienced or upset is, A, neither a crime, B, not the end of the world. You do not have ownership over somebody else's emotional reactions. The same way they don't have ownership over yours, even if they make that seem that way or make it feel like you do. This feels, I think, near impossible at the beginning. I'm going to tell you that. It goes against such a deeply held belief for us good girls, which is just don't upset people and everything will be okay. And you know what? I actually think that's a good rule to have. Don't be mean to people. Don't upset people. But we're specifically talking about situations where protecting their feelings and not upsetting them comes at the expense of our own feelings.
生活。你知道，某人感到不便或心烦，A，既不是犯罪，B，也不是世界末日。你对别人的情绪反应没有所有权。就像他们对你的情绪没有所有权一样，即使他们让情况看起来那样，或者让你觉得你有。我认为这在开始时几乎是不可能的。我会告诉你。这违背了我们乖乖女深信不疑的信念，那就是“不要让人生气，一切都会好起来的”。你知道吗？我其实认为这是一个很好的规则。不要对人刻薄。不要让人生气。但我们特别谈论的是那些保护他们的感受、不让他们生气是以牺牲我们自己的感受为代价的情况。
So two questions to ask yourself. You know, if you're worried about upsetting person, is it your intention to harm this person or is it your intention to respect yourself? And secondly, is this person actually being harmed if I'm disappointing them or are they just uncomfortable because I'm no longer behaving in a way that they prefer? I think another thing, sorry, I said two questions. The third thing is like, are they even considering your feelings in the way that you're considering theirs. Would they ever have as much anxiety and worry about letting you down
所以问自己两个问题。你知道，如果你担心让某人生气，你的意图是伤害这个人，还是你的意图是尊重你自己？其次，如果我让他们失望了，这个人真的受到了伤害吗？还是他们只是因为我不再表现出他们喜欢的样子而感到不舒服？我想还有一件事，抱歉，我说两个问题。第三件事是，他们是否像你考虑他们那样考虑你的感受？他们是否会像你现在担心让他们失望一样，
as you have about letting them down right now? Would they ever give it a second thought? I think maybe it's time to stop being considerate in situations where you were never even being considered. They didn't consider you. They didn't think about you once. You're doing all the thinking. Maybe it would be a healthy lesson for them to learn around just a healthy, calmic lesson. This is actually something a therapist of mine once said to me. I'm just going to steal it directly from her. Sometimes the nicest thing that you can do for somebody else is to disappoint them. And that seems counterintuitive, but you just can't gentle parent your way through every
担心让你失望？他们会三思而后行吗？我想也许是时候停止在那些你从未被考虑过的情况下表现得体贴了。他们没有考虑你。他们一次都没有想到你。你一直在思考。也许对他们来说，学习一个健康的、冷静的教训会是一个健康的课程。这其实是我的一位治疗师曾经对我说的。我打算直接借用她的话。有时你能为别人做的最友善的事情就是让他们失望。这看起来有悖常理，但你不能在每一段
relationship and hope that they're fruitful. You're just going to be exhausted and your friends, colleagues, partners, strangers, they're not your children. They're not your babies. They're adults who should be able to experience the, complexity of human emotion and human needs and how those sometimes contradict and not throw a tantrum and have the emotional maturity to deal with that. And that was a really helpful reframe for me. You know, it's actually a gift. What a gift it is to be direct with somebody. What a gift it is
关系中都用“温柔育儿”的方式，并希望它们富有成果。你只会精疲力竭，而你的朋友、同事、伴侣、陌生人，他们不是你的孩子。他们不是你的宝宝。他们是成年人，应该能够体验人类情感和需求的复杂性，以及这些需求有时如何相互矛盾，而不是发脾气，并拥有处理这些问题的成熟情感。这对我来说是一个非常有帮助的重构。你知道，这其实是一份礼物。直接告诉某人真相是一份多么好的礼物。这是一份多么好的礼物，
to let somebody else really know where I stand. What a gift it is to let somebody experience an uncomfortable emotion and take care of it in a way that may actually broaden how they see the world. You know, what a gift to give them emotional responsibility and the kind of emotional complexity that you probably had decades ago. One more psychology term that explains this, because I think it's really important. This term specifically comes from family psychology, and it's this idea of the differentiation of the self. The differentiation of the self is a state of psychological maturity in which we can distinguish between other's thoughts, feelings, emotions, and our own, and we can understand that occasional conflict or the existence of frustration
让别人真正知道我的立场。让某人体验一种不舒服的情绪并以一种可能实际上拓宽他们看待世界方式的方式来处理它，这是一份多么好的礼物。你知道，赋予他们情感责任和那种你可能几十年前就拥有的情感复杂性，是一份多么好的礼物。还有一个解释这一点的心理学术语，因为我认为它非常重要。这个术语专门来自家庭心理学，就是“自我分化”的概念。“自我分化”是一种心理成熟状态，在这种状态下，我们可以区分他人的思想、感受、情绪和我们自己的，我们可以理解偶尔的冲突或挫折的存在
or disappointment in another person does not, will not undermine the relationship if the relationship is healthy and is also not always about us. Other people's feelings are not always our responsibility. That is probably the most critical thing you can take away from this. You're not trouble. Other people's emotions are not your responsibility. It is actually a kindness in many ways to let somebody feel and be responsible for their own emotions the way that you have been for so long because it's insane that they could have gone through their entire life not figuring this out already. And often we have to take responsibility for the fact that maybe that's because we didn't let them. And so if we want the relationship, any relationship to evolve on better
或者另一个人的失望，如果关系是健康的，就不会、也不会破坏这种关系，而且也不总是关于我们。别人的感受并不总是我们的责任。这可能是你能从中得出的最关键的一点。你没有惹麻烦。别人的情绪不是你的责任。在很多方面，让某人感受并为自己的情绪负责，就像你长期以来所做的那样，实际上是一种善意，因为他们竟然能过完一生还没弄明白这一点，这太疯狂了。而且我们经常不得不承担责任，因为也许那是因为我们没有让他们负责。所以如果我们想要任何关系在更好的
terms and to be better and more mature, sometimes we have to just accept that discomfort is a part of relationships. And rushing in and trying to clean up the mess or the messes of everybody else around us is not always the nicest thing that we can do for them and definitely isn't the most helpful thing we can do for us if we're trying to unlearn these very deep, complex behaviors around our worth as a person and how that's wrapped up in us being a good girl. So that, my friends, that's everything. Everything for this episode, everything I have to say for now. If we had the time, I could so go further into some of the feminist psychology that I've been reading about.
条件下发展，变得更好、更成熟，有时我们必须接受不适是关系的一部分。冲进去试图清理我们周围每个人的烂摊子并不总是我们能为他们做的最友善的事情，如果我们试图摆脱这些关于我们作为一个人的价值以及这如何与我们做一个乖乖女纠缠在一起的非常深刻、复杂的行为，这绝对不是我们能做的最有帮助的事情。所以，我的朋友们，这就是全部。这一集的内容就是这些，我目前要说的就是这些。如果我们有时间，我可以更深入地探讨我一直在阅读的一些女性主义心理学。
But there will be links in the description. And honestly, the episode could have gone on for two hours. So if you do want a whole episode on feminist psychology, please let me know on the comments. Or you can send me a DM on Instagram, which is at That Psychology Podcast. if you're interested. Or maybe you're not, so then don't message me. But I really appreciate you tuning in for this episode. And I hope that if you relate to the characteristics of good girl syndrome or the good
但描述中会有链接。老实说，这一集本来可以持续两个小时。所以如果你确实想要一整集关于女性主义心理学的节目，请在评论中告诉我。或者你可以在Instagram上给我发私信，账号是@That Psychology Podcast，如果你感兴趣的话。或者也许你不感兴趣，那就别给我发消息。但我真的很感谢你收听这一集。我希望如果你与“乖乖女综合症”或“乖乖女”的特征产生共鸣，
girl complex, that this episode has just given you some guidance, maybe just some solace, that it's okay. We're all trying to unlearn this. It's okay if this is how you survived. But somebody being upset at you is, as I said, not a crime and not the end of the world. So I hope you get to experience that freedom. And I hope that, you know, just generally that we are one of the last generations where we'll need to discuss this. And we'll need to discuss kind of the burden of being a good girl and what that does to our own lives.
情结，这一集能给你一些指导，也许只是一些慰藉，没关系。我们都在努力摆脱这种心态。如果这是你生存的方式，也没关系。但正如我所说，别人对你生气不是犯罪，也不是世界末日。所以我希望你能体验到那种自由。我希望，你知道，总的来说，我们是最后几代需要讨论这个问题的人之一。我们需要讨论做一个乖乖女的负担，以及它对我们自己的生活造成了什么影响。
So thank you as always to our researcher, Lucy Davidson, for her help and research with this episode. If you want more psychology content just like this, you can watch our episodes on Netflix. Or you can follow us on Substack. and if you become a paid subscriber, you can receive articles and studies direct to your inbox twice a week. It's literally like the cost of a cup of coffee. You can also leave a five-star review, or you can send this episode to a friend if you feel called to do so, especially a friend who you think may relate, maybe in the same boat as you. Maybe they could benefit from it. But until next time, be safe. I was going to say be kind, but be assertive. Be safe. Be assertive. Be gentle to yourself.
所以一如既往地感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森，感谢她对本集的帮助和研究。如果你想要更多像这样的心理学内容，你可以观看我们在Netflix上的剧集。或者你可以在Substack上关注我们。如果你成为付费订阅者，你可以每周两次直接在收件箱中收到文章和研究报告。这简直就像一杯咖啡的钱。你也可以留下五星好评，或者如果你觉得有必要，可以将这一集发送给朋友，尤其是你认为可能会产生共鸣的朋友，也许他们和你处境相同。也许他们能从中受益。但下次见之前，注意安全。我本来想说要友善，但要坚定。注意安全。要坚定。对自己温柔一点。
talk very, very soon. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft.
很快再聊。嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔海恩。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。
Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
加入我们的欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者小组。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。
Hey everybody, it's me, Debbie Kamaabelle. This season on my podcast who's with me, I speak with Bruce Lee's daughter, Brandon Lee's sister, and my friend, Shannon Lee. Back to your initial point of stewarding my father's legacy and giving my energy to that. You're lending your life to stewarding somebody else's life. Listen to Who's With Me with Debbie Kmart Bell on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Pice Thomas, and on this season of the Black Lit podcast, we're outside asking why.
嘿大家好，是我，黛比·卡马贝尔。本季在我的播客《Who's With Me》中，我与李小龙的女儿、李国豪的妹妹，也是我的朋友香农·李交谈。回到你最初的观点，即管理我父亲的遗产并将我的精力投入其中。你是在把你的生命借给别人来管理别人的生活。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听黛比·卡马贝尔的《Who's With Me》。是否存在针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，是黑人文学。我是杰克·奎斯特-派斯·托马斯，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们正在外面询问原因。
They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella Bakers, Michael Maxes and Martin Luther King's running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, the only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. What up? This Jay Valentine co-host of the R&B Money Podcast alongside my brother, R&B legend, Tank. Together, we've built a space for artists, executives, and fans of R&B music to reminisce and tell the real stories behind the music. have no money. I was hood famous. They think you're going to get everybody out. We lived in a project. Real love came out. They're hearing the music and we had nothing.
他们不想要一大堆小艾拉·贝克、马尔科姆·X和马丁·路德·金到处跑。当你观察许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。怎么了？我是杰伊·瓦伦丁，与我的兄弟、R&B传奇人物Tank一起主持《R&B Money》播客。我们共同为R&B音乐的艺术家、高管和粉丝建立了一个空间，让他们回忆并讲述音乐背后的真实故事。没钱。我当时在街区很有名。他们以为你会把每个人都带出来。我们住在廉租房里。真正的爱出现了。他们听到了音乐，而我们一无所有。
From Smokey Robinson to Mary J. Blige, B2K to Jill Scott. If you're a super dedicated R&B fan, this is where you belong. Listen to R&B money from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeartRadio Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, this is Robert Lamb. And this is Joe McCormick, and we're the host of the Stuff to Blow Your Mind podcast. This week on the show, it's Star Trek. So we're going to be talking about the Borg all week long. Are you ready to get some probes put in your flesh? That's right. Tune in. Resistance is futile. We're going to talk science, the culture of the borg, various interpretations, and we're going to talk about Star Trek First Contact on Weird House Cinema on Friday.
从斯莫基·罗宾逊到玛丽·J·布莱姬，从B2K到吉尔·斯科特。如果你是一个超级忠实的R&B粉丝，这就是你所属的地方。在iHeartRadio Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《R&B Money》。嘿，我是罗伯特·兰姆。我是乔·麦克考密克，我们是《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》播客的主持人。本周节目主题是《星际迷航》。所以我们整周都会讨论博格人。你准备好让一些探测器植入你的肉体了吗？没错。敬请收听。抵抗是徒劳的。我们将讨论科学、博格文化、各种解读，我们还将在周五的《怪异电影院》中讨论《星际迷航：第一类接触》。
Listen to Stuff to Blow Your Mind on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Stuff to Blow Your Mind》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证人类创作。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。